Before, you could see us renovating this old ruin.
The whole thing is not straight at all.
No wall is 90 degree in here,
and they're just built very sketchy...
So, we built a wooden frame inside
that would carry the load of the roof.
We've also built back the broken top,
and now the wood and the bricks are connected to each other.
So, now, we actually have one
solid structure to continue with.
Now that the ruin walls are connected again,
we can finally cut our last hole right there.
We didn't do this before, because we were a bit skeptical,
if the wall would actually hold it...
And, we will use the bricks we get,
to close the old entrance right there.
So, in this video, we're going to make a cut,
patch back a wall, and build a window frame.
And Martijn and Adrian are going to make it!
So, first step, we are going to cut the bricks,
to open a window.
We are not really sure about this.
So, we have these old concrete...
But, we are not sure,
if it's going to really hold the full wall.
So, we are going to add a metal lintel here for that.
We also have Martijn, the expert from the Netherlands
to help us.
Hi! My name is Martijn!
I'm a maker and, I just had my birthday here, and I turned 33!
In my last job, I was an engineer for a company
that makes cardboard houses.
And now, I'm at Project Kamp to help
make a sketchy ruin less sketchy.
Besides making things, I like to make music.
And, I love dancing!
Someday, I would like to live
in a community with my girlfriend.
Let's see what the future brings!
First cut!
We have cut this size, because then,
we can straight away put it in the door.
It will fit exactly the same there.
So, let's work, let’s clean the tiles...
The wall was still stuck...
And, we had to do some more cutting...
So, we finished the first half of the hole for the window!
And, before I continue, I'm going to make sure that all
of what's left here, is not going to fall on my head...
I'm going to put a metal support in this corner.
All the cuts in the wall have been made,
and now it's time to take out the last bit of wall.
The cut is ready!
We are still alive.
And, look at the view!
So, the next step, we place the metal lintel on top.
We will introduce it in the wall,
while making some cuts.
We fill the gap with cement
to make everything a bit more sturdy.
The next step is to put the steel lintel in position.
And, to get it up to the right height.
All right!
Now, we have the lintel in place.
We're going to put cement over here,
and in that corner to keep it in place.
So, on both sides, we've now filled the space
between the lintel and the bricks.
It's already starting to dry a little bit.
And now, we're just going to be filling
on the other side of the wall.
Before, you could see that we were filling in the space,
between the brick and the metal lintel.
But, as you can see...
These bricks are all hollow.
Probably not so strong...
So, we're going to fill all the gaps,
withsome cement to make it a bit more strong.
We've been cutting the hole before.
This used to be a door, and we were going to close it,
because we made a door on the side.
We like to reuse stuff.
So, we decided to use the whole section,
and just put it in place.
After this is in place,
we'll use new bricks to fill in the top.
For the big hole we cut in the wall now,
we are going to make a window frame.
We got gifted some really nice,
insulated glass panels by Ronald.
A Dutch guy that lives around here.
Thanks, Ronald, for that!
And, around those glass panels,
we're going to make a wooden window frame.
We asked some local woodworkers
to give us a jump start.
By making some really nice straight timber
for us, with a nice groove to put the glass.
So, we've got eight windows,
First, we're going to make an outside frame.
Then, in the middle, we're going to place another vertical one.
And then, we have three horizontals,
to end up with eight windows.
So, here's the design for the window frame!
The window frame itself is made up of
an outside frame, and an inside frame.
The glass panels sit in a groove
that's cut into wooden beams.
And, they are held in place by a glazing bar.
Today, Emma is going to help me.
Let's start cutting!
- That's me, baby!
Just finished the window frame!
It’s over there!
I'm pretty happy with it.
It's nice and tight!
There's not so much steady machinery and flat surfaces...
So, I'm pretty happy how it turned out!
- It's like this, I think?
So, we already put the window on.
We tried to solve a couple of problems
we have in this ruin.
One of them is, like, there's
not a single surface that is leveled.
Nothing is balanced.
Nothing is square.
As you can see here, like, this wall is a bit like this...
Then, this wall is not square with this one....
So, we are going to make a frame now,
to be able to level all our new surfaces a bit.
Including the window, and the window is already level.
We need to put it higher a bit on one side,
than on the other one, in order to have it level.
And then, when the window is level,
also the water will flow in a better way.
If we don't have the window level,
the water will be stuck in some places...
So, the next step is to build the frame around,
fix it and continue with the job!
We have test-fitted the window frame
in the hole, and it fits pretty well!
I gave it some sanding, and I've cleaned up the edges of the frame
with a router, to make it all nice and smooth.
Now, it's time to paint it.
We're going to use a clear coat varnish,
in order to keep the wood good for a longer time.
And besides that, it's going to be painted.
It's going to be under overhang of the roof,
which will protect the window frame from rain and the sun.
Which is going to make it last for a longer time!
Now that the window frame has been painted,
in a nice, clear varnish, you can still see the beautiful pinewood.
We are going to put the glass.
The glass is going to sit in this wooden groove.
To make a nice and airtight connection,
between the glass and the wood...
We're going to put foam
strips in the wooden groove.
When the glass is in place,
we're going to secure it with a glazing bar.
And, the glazing bar has these foam strips as well
to secure the glass.
It's a little bit off the edge, so you have a nice space
for silicon to go, and make a watertight connection!
Around the window frame, we're making a nice granite edge.
To close the bricks, and to finish it off nice!
- Let’s get it up!
It's hot!
- Hot!
Very hot!
And, a small hole, I see?
- A really small hole.
The granite is in place all the way around!
The final cleaning!
The window is ready.
Granite is ready.
- One, two, three...
Cool! That was it!
Window is in place.
View is in place.
Glass is in place.
The walls are closed.
And, that was it for this week!
Thank you for watching!
If you want to know more about this ruin,
you can go to the research topic.
You can find the link below.
And, see you next week!